[Musique]
bonjour Brice Lambert vous êtes
journaliste documentariste vous venez
nous parler ce matin de ce film que vous
signez cela s'appelle femme en peine les
oubliés de l'Amérique on va entre
apercevoir quelques images dans un
instant un document assez édifiant sur
la situation carcérale des femmes aux
États-Unis c'est le pays au monde qui
est cassé le plus de femmes un tiers des
femmes est cassée dans le monde sont
américaines elles sont aujourd'hui 230
000 c'est un chiffre qui a été multiplié
par 7 en 35 ans vous êtes rendu dans
l'Oklahoma pour tourner ce film question
déjà de pédagogie de géographie
l'Oklahoma où est-ce qu'on est
un état de taille moyenne c'est à peu
près 4 millions d'habitants c'est un
état qui se situe au sud des États-Unis
un état qui est frontalié du Texas
peut-être que les le public situe mieux
le Texas donc on est on est pas très
loin de la frontière mexicaine
finalement et c'est un état oui de
taille moyenne géographiquement c'est un
état relativement pauvre c'est le
dixième état le plus pauvre des
États-Unis
et c'est un état qu'on pourrait
qualifier de conservateurs voire ultra
conservateur qui se situe dans ce qui
s'appelle aux États-Unis la Bible Belt
la ceinture biblique pour peu que la
traduction soit soit correcte c'est un
état vous relevez dans les dirigeants
d'une vision très misogyne très
évangélique très fondamentaliste des
questions de délinquance alors il y a
dans cette dans cette zone des
États-Unis une grande place qui est
faite et qui est donnée à la religion
elle est partout elle est partout dans
les rues elle est partout dans les dans
les mots et elle est partout y compris
dans les cercles de pouvoir et elle a
effectivement une influence sur la loi
elle a une influence sur les décisions
et probablement sur en tout cas c'est
l'analyse que font des spécialistes la
fin de ces questions sur la manière dont
les décisions de justice sont prises le
film s'ouvre sur un atelier d'écriture
dans une prison des détenus lisses des
poèmes qu'elles ont écrit en substance
elles disent quoi elles disent je suis
brisé je suis maltraité je suis abusé je
suis oublié quel est le profil de sa
prisonnière alors c'est bon c'est
toujours complexe de faire un portrait
robot comme ça mais bon en général ce
sont des mers 80% d'entre elles des
femmes issues de milieu sociaux plutôt
défavorisés pour à peu près 70% d'entre
elles dans l'Oklahoma ce sont des femmes
qui n'ont pas de diplôme ce sont des
femmes qui
sont dans une oui une de des vies
cabossés des histoires de vie cabosser
ce sont pour 30% d'entre elles des
femmes noires les minorités sont sur
représentées dans les prisons voilà si
on devait faire un portrait robot ça
pourrait correspondre à ça et justement
on propose à ceux qui nous rejoignent
mais suivra un petit extrait de votre
film c'est un sénateur local qui dit
justement qui décrit le profil de ces
personnes en Détentation dans l'État de
l'Oklahoma aux États-Unis
de l'Amérique signé Brice Lambert que
nous recevons aujourd'hui système donc
extrêmement dur avec les plus fragiles
une femme qui tombe enceinte en étant
toxicoman est sanctionnée parce qu'elle
est tombée enceinte alors qu'elle est
toxicoman l'État de l'Oklahoma juge que
c'est de sa faute oui c'est une approche
non pas par
la santé le soin c'est une approche
punitive donc effectivement une femme
qui se présente à l'hôpital pour
accoucher et qui est toxicomane elle a
de grandes chances de terminer en prison
si on peut perdre la garde là c'est le
c'est la catastrophe brist Lambert qui
est très très présent dans votre film
cet élément c'est la drogue sous
plusieurs formes que ce soit des métaux
étamines des opiacés la droite qui fait
des ravages absolument incalculable et
cela crée une sorte de cercle vicieux
pour les personnes qui se retrouvent en
détention alors oui c'est la drogue est
une des grandes raisons voir la raison
principale de l'explosion de la
population carcérale féminine bon il y a
une épidémie de drogue aux Etats-Unis je
rappelle qu'elle est dernière les
États-Unis ont battu un record c'est
plus de 100 000 morts par overdose
n'était jamais arrivé les opioïdes dont
on entend beaucoup parler
en fait amine qui qui sont très
présentes et les États-Unis depuis les
années 70 et la fameuse guerre à la
drogue qu'ils ont guerre contre la
drogue qu'ils ont déclenché le président
Nixon tout à fait en 71 on enferme les
toxicomanes on enferme les petits
trafiquants les femmes ont été beaucoup
plus touchées que les hommes par cette
politique parce que souvent elle n'était
pas les les grands dealers celle qui qui
tenaient les ficelles du business mais
elles étaient celles qui étaient dans la
rue c'était les les les les dealers en
fin de course si j'allais dire et elles
ont donc subi de plein fouet les
conséquences de cette politique très
répressive ce taux carcérale Brice
Lambert même si elle a cette défenseur
parce qu'on entend quelqu'un dans le
film qui dit en Oklahoma tout le monde a
le droit d'aller en prison même si ce
tout carcéral à sa défenseur il ne
marche pas mais maintenant si un
directeur de prison le Deep je vous
propose de réécouter puisque c'est vous
qui avez tourné une séquence avec une
magistrate dit justement qu'est-ce
qu'elle pense de cette politique menée
dans l'État de l'Oklahoma
l'incarcération
de je crois qu'il est important de
montrer aux gens qu'il ne s'agit pas
juste d'échapper à la prison et de s'en
tenir là il faut rendre des comptes
il y a du soin il y a un suivi avec un
agent probation il y a des tests de
dépistage de drogue
réussir ce programme demande plus
d'efforts que d'aller en prison
ce genre d'alternative ce n'est pas du
laxisme c'est une manière efficace de
combattre le crime
le programme dont elle parle c'est un
programme qui s'appelle woman in
littéralement des femmes qui sont en
processus de soins prochaine question
Brice Lambert dans tout ce que vous
décrivez il y a quand même un peu
d'espoir puisque justement il y a une
approche par le soin et une fine et
visant une réinsertion de ces personnes
alors peut-être pour commencer un peu de
contexte 80% de ces femmes incarcérées
le son pour des crimes qui sont non
violents et pour une grande partie
d'entre elles au moins 60% ce sont des
crimes liés aux drogues et donc il y a
des initiatives et qui sont en partie
financées par des fonds privés faut
quand même le préciser c'est c'est pas
c'est pas beaucoup les fonds publics qui
financent les initiatives là ont une
approche de soins c'est-à-dire on va
essayer de soigner une addiction on va
essayer de soigner les causes de cette
addiction qui sont souvent des
traumatismes les femmes sont plus
sujettes aux violences aux violences
conjugales aux violences psychologiques
que les hommes souvent elles ont recours
à des drogues pour ce qu'on appelle de
l'automédication et donc ces approches
oui essaie plutôt de régler les
problèmes profonds plutôt que de punir
on a affaire à des épouses on a affaire
à des sœurs on a affaire à des mers
Brice Lambert qu'en est-il des enfants
on ne peut pas les oublier dans cette
situation alors effectivement une des
une des
conséquences oubliées de ce problème ce
sont les enfants en 80% de ces femmes
sont des mers souvent ce sont des mers
le seul qui allège leurs enfants seuls
toujours c'est parcours brisés c'est
parcours cassés et il y a en Oklahoma
mais c'est le cas aussi ailleurs aux
États-Unis 100 000 enfants qui
grandissent avec au moins un de leurs
parents en prison et ça a des
conséquences graves on essaie de le
montrer dans le film ça des conséquences
évidemment psychologiques sur leur
développement et puis statistiquement on
sait que un enfant dont l'un des parents
est en prison à 6 fois plus de risques
de finir un jour lui-même derrière les
barreaux donc il y a comme ça une il
voulait une reproduction sociale on se
passe entre guillemets la prison de
génération en génération qu'est-ce qui
vous a le plus marqué en tournant ce
film quelle séquence quelle image alors
il y en a plusieurs parce que c'était
des histoires fortes mais mais mais si
je devais en retenir une c'est peut-être
justement cette séquence de fin où nous
sommes avec une grand-mère qui a entre
guillemets récupéré la garde de ces
quatre petits-enfants dont un est né en
prison et
qui se trouvait dans une situation
économique très compliquée
elle vit dans une maison très modeste
c'est un milieu défavorisé et elle
devait assumer ça la garde de ses
enfants puisque sa fille est en prison
il y avait dans cette image tous les
marqueurs de de une situation difficile
qui pourrait conduire ses enfants un
jour vers du crime vers de la prison et
effectivement c'est assez dur à voir
parce que on voit que le cercle n'est
pas brisé on trouve s'attendre presque à
ce que la situation perdure femme en
peine les oublier de l'Amérique il y a
diffusé demain sur Public Sénat
qu'est-ce que vous brist Lambert vous
voulez que le public en haute tienne
alors j'aimerais surtout que le public
se pose des questions mais si je devais
choisir quelque chose je dirais que
il faut se méfier des solutions simples
lorsque les problèmes sont complexes là
on est face à un problème complexe la
réponse simple qui est mettons tout le
monde en prison
n'est pas forcément la bonne peut-être
que la chose ne bougeront pas forcément
quand on voit les résultats de ces
élections de vie mandat aux États-Unis
dans l'État de l'uklaoma plus exactement
un dernier mot alors l'État de
l'Oklahoma effectivement votre
républicain majoritairement ils ont voté
Trump aux dernières élections à 65%
c'était le cas au dernier mythme mais
peut-être point positif
l'avortement était en sondage sorti
d'urne une des principales
préoccupations des Américains loin
derrière l'économie mais c'était un
sujet de préoccupation et aujourd'hui le
cloudma et l'État qui a la législation
la plus stricte sur le Cloud donc oui
la situation
peut durer mais on on voit que le droit
des femmes devient un sujet aux
États-Unis merci beaucoup wislander
merci à nos journalistes documentariste
réalisateur de femmes en peine les
oubliées de l'Amérique film à retrouver
demain sur Public Sénat c'était invité
de Paris direct